son varios proyectos Hoy es el Día de
Nicho de la Francia sumisa el partido de
izquierda esto quiere decir que el
partido presenta muchas propuestas de
ley la más importante es esta que
inscribe el derecho al aborto en la
Constitución sin embargo el próximo
lunes es el Día de Nicho del partido de
gobierno renacimientos y también ellos
tienen una propuesta de ley en este
sentido la de hoy ha recibido muchas
enmiendas de parte de los partidos de
derecha y de extrema derecha porque se
oponen justamente aquí este derecho sea
inscrito en la Constitución ellos
prefieren hablar simplemente de
inscribir la ley 20 de 1975 que instauró
el derecho al aborto pero no de la
contracepción volante y Concepción que
está inscrita en este proyecto de la
fragancia por lo tanto todavía se está
analizando este texto los diputados han
presentado su oposición sus enmiendas y
se espera quizás que se vote a eso de
las cinco de la tarde dentro oscuras y
luego se voten otros proyectos por
ejemplo aquel que prohíbe la corrida de
toros o que pretende aumentar el sueldo
mínimo a 1600 euros e incluso otro
proyecto para reincorporar a las
personas al personal médico que no se
quiso vacunar durante el 19 pero el gran
freno que van a tener ambos proyectos
que quieren inscribir a la Constitución
al derecho al aborto es el senado que es
de mayoría de derecha y que tiene
también una importante representación
del centro y de la extrema derecha de
sectores conservadores de hecho ya el 19
de octubre hubo otro proyecto de varios
partidos de todos los partidos que fue
rechazado por el senado justamente
porque se oponían a este texto ellos
prefieran como les decía ustedes
inscribir la ley porque eso permite
además controlar que la mujer pueda
abordar hasta la semana 14 según ellos
Si eso no se fija las mujeres francesas
podrían abordar hasta al final Quizás
quizás de su embarazo